you take calls on your podcast you talk
to total strangers right and you never
know what's gonna happen when they call
but you just go with it
well I you know we and we attempt to
give them like advice which usually ends
up being horrible because we're
unqualified on't know what the title is
unqualified you kind of yeah you're
you're you're okay but it started
because I used to do this I used to play
this thing called chatroulette which I
don't know if some people know but I
think it's off now I think they stopped
doing Cheryl that but how long ago was
chatroulette this is like this is like
around 2008-2009 somewhere right around
in there yeah and and it for me it was
awesome because I got to talk to total
strangers you get to really pick and
choose you know you can instantly next
somebody and then sudden suddenly you're
in like you know Romania with a bunch of
drunk dudes and then you next them and
then you're in the Philippines with the
librarian it was amazing like a while
right but then it quickly became all
penises yeah don't you like that was
knowing I had friends that were into it
and they would say like that it was just
like every fourth one's like another
penis yes yeah disappointing to me but
for a minute my friends and I would do
this thing because out of like my anger
towards the warping of this cool thing
and you know because it really was just
notice something so right and then as
always happens right the penis enters
the picture yeah so as sort of a weird
kind of revenged we would start to cheer
these guys on like so we would click on
somebody and you just see a penis in the
hand going doing its thing and we would
be like yeah right right and we would be
like yeah yeah you can do it let's go
come on
we just destroyed that did we would get
nexted to the next penis right away
right it was amazing it's it's it is too
bad that think beautiful things on the
internet yeah beautiful things get
warped always by people's sexual
fantasies just thinking about it now
you